hi everyone I'm milano Chara Lanza and I
am currently playing a remake of one of
my favorite games ever which is a fable
anniversary it's the remake of sable 1 /
people TLC which is way way way better
than all of the other fable games just
quietly and I decided to play the arena
today so i'm recording it on my Elgato
and to be honest i'm pretty sure i
haven't done this in years so i think
i'll still remember how everything goes
slow because this games just so
excellent like the order of things i'm
pretty good i know there's some bal
vereen's in there and some other stuff
and i have a lot of money that i may as
well just blow so let's just do this but
i'm playing it with like an anniversary
you you get to choose between the combat
style of favor one or the combat style
of fable two and three and I have
definitely it shows in the combat style
of favor one and if you don't do this
then you are wrong lack of introduction
we have a full stadium and they want
action I'm wrath I look after everything
behind the scenes here if you need me a
pair it's about fighting in the arena
come and talk to me come and talk to me
hey that was terabyte it's not anything
like him but yeah nice nice 10 douchebag
that's no no it's not I don't know what
else to say except that it sucks alright
so I'm pretty sure they don't let me out
straight away because someone else's
other
can't let you in chameleon is still
getting butchered I hope you're going to
put up a better fight than he is really
so nasally and I'm pretty sure these
guys like talked about bees or something
I don't know I don't remember I don't
remember but yeah I since I love fable
one so much my opinion on fable 2 / 3
was really bad because i love this game
specifically for the combat which is
kind of why I chose to do chameleons the
arena did what already you idiot right
people it seems chameleon only made it
for three rounds before dying like a
chicken in front of 5,000 a thousand
need a new volunteer new man you look
ready in you go damn right I'm ready
talk to I'll apply the door he'll let
you into the arena so in case you
couldn't tell a slash if you have played
the games before you will be able to
tell that i am a will user predominantly
which means like i use magic i'm always
a mage in pretty much every RPG i play
because why if you're gonna play an RPG
why would you not want to do it with
like the ability to use sweet magic
right I thought you in now you sure
you're ready sure you're ready yes I am
Oh round one I always tell me this one
gives them the biggest our vows yep end
of this game as well I'm sorry but yeah
so the lines all over my face because I
have will but I do also use a sword
which are usually augment with lightning
and silver
right now obviously is fire and I think
silvo's
to win believe like other braid
challengers coming soon keen my number
one fan thanks buddy I appreciate that
yeah yeah you repeat that animation
that's what really gets me going right
this is actually pretty good me remake
collect graphically everything's you
know vaguely improved the only real
issue with it like I was worried I'd be
so disappointed but the only real issue
that I have with it is that there's like
weird little jari bits oh no that's the
wrong one this is what we want screen
yeah just like jobs sometimes
and I think oh the reason why for the
combatants one particularly is because
you can use multiple spells at once like
right now I'm using a shield spell which
means that all of my damage actually
goes to
my help which is super super super handy
because it means that you have the
sinkhole to called kombat x which is
this thing that currently has five his
training and that
and yes I'm using that right now but I
also have like I had that it's called
like double sword fighting like that
double hit or something enter from the
actual name of the spell its eyes by it
I don't I don't put it that far ahead
and yet like double hits things and you
know you can you can use like pretty
much be heaps of spells at once in a way
cool away than fable two and three with
their like crappy combining things so I
don't know I'm this and kingdoms of our
little every speaking of love the combat
system Hobbs ok homes are annoying it's
held so hit the ones that use magic
because they the biggest dicks all right
all right wow he went down faster than I
expected alright everything's going well
on it on it
you can't change your name of this but I
kind of like chicken chaser oh yeah and
the crowd of currently throwing things
at me because I'm so next
yeah have money that'd be nice I wonder
if that's what PewDiePie feels like
constantly why are these people throwing
so much money at me
Wow look at that XP
okay let me go screw old why don't I
even have here i have a healy thingy and
also cool uses up my moma nothing I
would like that so yeah like anyone who
is to play the fable two and three
combat style over this one I just I just
can't understand why you're alive I'm
sorry but I just don't I just don't get
it man it's just it's like insulting and
while the other games that I think that
terrible I thought fable 3 is pretty bad
because most
while it's leaked applica stupidly easy
and the combat we should so tedious that
it almost like hurt my hands from all
the goddamn tapping table tools all
right but just compared to this they're
just so damn disappointing no you don't
I think that he gets hurt by that I
think I got hurt by that spinny bladi
thing but nobody else does which is all
these on no I ways obviously discovery
and my shields gone oh no that sucks I
totally would have got that damn it like
a second too late though screw you guys
three IGAs
anything
Oh what the hell you know I want to do
that yes thank you Jesus
yeah good aim yeah and I same a nice
pants yeah nice pants you guys like
coordinator outfits before you came I
wonder
maybe this cops don't have like a little
options for this kind of thing I'll go
learn so far there's a little bar on the
right look up please the audiences with
me look look at that clap meter yeah
let's do it oh hello yeah yeah you get
keen look I have a lady fan now today
hero why not clapped herself so this is
whisper who is like your childhood
friend / rival / mostly rival feel like
what she's wearing it's really cool
actually but that would be uncomfortable
that's like a kitchen faucet thing with
a scarf who is a scarf in battle look it
look at me like I'm not even wearing any
armor just because in RPGs I care way
more about the way I look than anything
else ever really oh and armor in this
game is often mismatch so I just don't
even bother
and not that cool like i was playing
this game neverwinter and as far as I
could tell it's an MMO and as far as I
could tell no matter what i did my
costume never actually changed so i was
like a not sure I want to continue this
because I was like getting higher levels
and stuff but just stayed looking the
same and I mean what's the point man
yeah I forgot you can target that's
right dog it suck it
yep yep everyone drop me any more money
that's so much stuff
kinda makes me feel cheap he's holding
that down though so let's let's just hey
you drop money thank you guys
ha
oh so close to walking on that thing all
right so good everything came up
milhouse don't even like the Simpsons
that much but I like the house everyone
likes no that's right
like that make sense
or if you guys can he meet African
buttons right now that would not
surprise me at all vigorously tapping
expert as bad as in table
dead two months
please these [ __ ] love me some kind
of new states
screw you guys
huh maybe she could do that in real life
haters be God huh
screw you guys
is whisper even do anything feel like I
feel like I'm doing most of this hey
I guess she killed anyone
get out
you
keep forgetting so many things like I
started playing it when it first came
out being anniversary that is and not a
game since then so you for getting like
some of the handiest of all of the
controls
Wow 1600 in the man and there's another
2,000 on Arbor for the next round
obviously it we're going to continue to
the next round